do you believe that there is one God
worthy of worship that God is one I do
okay do you believe in God sending
Messengers to mankind I do okay do you
believe in Revelation that God has sent
to these Messengers I do do you believe
in angels that Allah has used to send
Revelation to The Messengers I do do you
believe in the day of judgment
I do do you believe in Divine decree and
predestination from Allah I do okay
perfect so we're going to read it out in
Arabic first and then we're going to do
it in English all right okay okay so Ash
hadu foreign
that there is none worthy of worship
except Allah except Allah and I bear
witness and I bear witness that the
prophet Muhammad that the prophet
Muhammad is the servant is the servant
and messenger of Allah and messenger of
Allah oh my
God thank you guys
this has been such a like a long journey
for me bro for real
I can't hold it together but it's all
good he's a tears of joy bro sorry to do
this on the live but I've been through a
lot a lot of stuff in my life and this
means a lot for you guys to do this for
me I appreciate it I'm like I've been
watching you guys God's work is not easy
bro it's not for the week and you guys
are doing great work out here bro keep
on keeping on I put you on to my other
buddies and you know
they're gonna be they're going to be
here soon as well they just need a
little bit more of affirmation but um
yeah we're doing this bro thank you I
appreciate you guys go into this please
go into your story man
oh man my story We went on got enough
time for my story but uh I'll let you
know on a little bit um
I worked I worked you know regular drill
trucks Warehouse blah blah blah and then
I was making like 24 an hour you know
I'm saying I had a kid already
um payments all around and uh I made a
decision one day to say I I quit I just
quit because I'm an artist I do
photography I went to college for that
and I said I just quit I didn't go in
the next day and I just said I needed to
chase a dream that was about like six
years six or seven years ago I went
through the bottom bro my like I was
late on child support laid on all my
bills laid on everything but I kept
pushing I did not want to go back to a
nine to five to work for somebody else
and God willing bro everything worked
out beautifully and the more bro the
more that I was in tune with my
spirituality and getting closer to God
the more everything cleared up for me
even
and and just happen even better and
better the closer I got her to God it
put more confidence in me to keep on
going it and like we're here now so now
I quit the job I run my own guitar I do
real estate photography for um I've been
in Boston magazine a couple of times now
uh I flip houses
um I'm about to sell this house I bought
I don't want to give numbers but we're
doubling up on this flip which is a
beautiful thing I gave my mom money I
gave my sister money it just like and
this all just happened like we are at
the peak of this so like this this all
just happened within the last like month
you know that I came up on this my dad
had a seven family he wanted to sell it
um
he didn't want to sell it I convinced
him to sell it because with the money we
could have done great things and right
now we're doing great things mom's happy
dad's happy sister's happy the kids are
good I'm good I'm in a nicer home nicer
environment everything's good my
business is great you know everything is
looking up and like this is the last
step for me right here this is the last
step so I can continue being as rich as
possible back in the day I smoked I
drinked and now I just I tell everybody
not to I tell everybody not to clear
your mind to make sure you're focused
because one drop of alcohol one smoke of
the weed it Alters your mind you can go
from being one person
right now I can be one person right now
go smoke a joint and have a hundred
thousand percent different thoughts
right away and that is dangerous so
it's just a beautiful thing I'm glad I
did this I've come so far like and like
I can't wait to like share this with my
children I know they're really young
right now and I can't like fully grasp
you know God and all this stuff but like
we're gonna do it I'm gonna I'm gonna
show them the Quran and show them the
way
of Islam and I have a girlfriend I do
have a question
I have a girlfriend uh we're not married
we have a child together
um
she is not Muslim yet but she is going
she she wants to be you know so maybe
she'll be on this live soon but I was
just confused a little bit like I don't
is it for marriage or like now that I'm
Muslim and she's not how does how does
that work
so I think it's best that we talk more
in depth after the stream just in
private about this but
um what's her belief I guess she a
Christian is she atheist
she was like an atheist like um not
believing I wouldn't say atheists I
would say like agnostic like believe
there was a high power just didn't know
what where to pick she's seen me go
through this now I mean she watches all
the videos with me she's right here with
me now so she's yeah she's on the same
path she's on the same path she she
understands it
um I would say she's 99 there I think
this right here is the one percent she's
gonna need to fully give herself I see I
see and that's a beautiful thing and I'm
glad that you know you could be an
example for those around you I think
it's a very beautiful thing and we're
very proud of you may Allah blessing
bless you and increase you inshallah
we're going to be here for you I would
say no worries inshallah um the way to
go in Islam is marriage you know no
matter what no matter who you are what
situation you're in and it's to preserve
of the rights of both you and especially
the rights of the woman you know the
rights of the wife and the sister in
this situation so
um once she is you know able to accept
Islam
um you know have her accept Islam she
could do it with us or with anyone else
and then getting married is very easy
right you don't have to do any long
drawn out process it doesn't even
necessarily need to be
um done and recognized by the state to
be recognized in the sight of Allah
um and like I said we could talk about
all this afterwards all you need to get
married are two male Witnesses uh
someone to conduct the ceremony a bridal
gift you're going to give her a gift you
know money or whatever you know she
asked for
and
um with her father's permission or you
know someone someone of uh of uh I guess
status you could say in her life but uh
in this case I think because she's just
accepting Islam it might be like the
Imam or the leader of a mosque so that's
really all you need okay sit down for
half an hour go through the ceremony and
then you guys will be married
sounds good
things stop moving fast bro things start
moving fast but um I'm ready I'm ready
for this bro I'm ready I just
this has been a crazy experience for me
man like so this is a beautiful thing I
cannot wait to just dive deep or do more
research and just really do the work
like now I feel like I can I can do the
work and I am like in my group I am the
person that everybody looks to like so
when they see me do this trust me
there's gonna be a lot around who will
question that they're gonna they're
gonna get into it so a lot of people
around me can't even believe I'm doing
this to be honest but um
you know like like like it said the
truth is there it's not for some it's
not to be convincing somebody else it's
like if the text is written you know
what I'm saying you gotta read it the
truth is in there and that's what I tell
everybody I'm like just open it up just
open it up and read I don't have to
explain it's all explained in there
literally yeah
there has to be no convincing this is
not like we know when you see like
Christian missionaries and trying to
like really get in your head bro yes yes
we can we can refute doubts and and
things that don't align with reality
the truth is already there the Quran is
the thing that is if anyone comes into
it with an open mind they don't need
anything else
um so they will create a group chat
inshallah with me brother Rami Angel and
you any other private matters we can
discuss there but I do have one last
question for you what would you um
answer to the brothers and sisters that
are kind of wondering I want to become
Muslim but I have way too many way too
many desires way too many things that
I'm caught up in and these are unislamic
things
um I would say if you're caught up in a
bunch of stuff that's not righteous or
doesn't feed your good into your soul
and
the moment you realize that the path of
righteousness is the path that you
should take and your life will become
better no matter what even if you don't
become a Muslim right away the path to
become Muslim is an eye-opening and
spiritual experience in itself I would
say for the people who are like
struggling with that
open the book up read it do your
research even do read the Bible read
everything and then read the Quran it
will be so clear to you and it's in
times of spirituality you definitely
don't want to put toxins in your body
whether it's drinking whether it's
smoking whether it's
crazy you know s-e-x whatever you guys
are doing
it's all you wake up with a guilt when
you wake up with that guilt that's how
you know it's wrong everybody's got
those voices in their head that one that
says yo do this do this do this it's so
easy to do the devil's work and it's so
hard to do God's work but what what
comes from hard work you go to the gym
you never nobody wants to go to the gym
you pump those weights but you look you
look Godly you know what I'm saying you
look you're looking like a a huge guy it
sucks it's hard but you get the results
and it's the same thing with this if you
put the work in with your spirit and
your spirituality and you do what is
right you will reap the benefits at the
end no matter what and before me even
doing this like I've just been trying to
connect with God so much and he's just
put things in my
every piece has lined up perfectly with
the thought of righteousness positivity
and having God is with who want to guide
you through everything will line up and
that's that's coming from me somebody
who don't Came From The Bottom who don't
been through it all everything and I've
had I've always said I'm a guy who had
the worst luck anything that happens I
take two steps forward I take ten steps
back something always happens as soon as
I accepted this to myself
I've been taking steps forward and I've
never taken a step back from there and I
I keep I I just want to climb this
mountain and keep climbing it's
beautiful and the feeling you get from
being righteous is overwhelming when you
do good things it feels good when you do
bad things
you're gonna you will have to pay for
that at the end you will be judged for
everything that you do so start thinking
about that now and understand that that
thing in your mind that tells you yo
don't do this that's that's what you
need to listen to listen to that and go
towards that don't go to the other thing
that's easy no you can go to the club
and go to the bar whatever whatever
that's easy to do to do this work for
God that is hard bro even explaining
this to people is a hard thing to do to
come not to convince but to educate
people and to try to show them God is a
difficult thing as well you know what
I'm saying so
I would say to anybody
it's uh it's a hard it's a hard path but
it's worth it every step of the way is
worth it and at the end of it if you do
it and you race towards God you will be
the happiest person on the planet and
everything in your life will line up
perfectly 100 percent
inshallah those beautifully put together
bro
uh sister and uh brother Romy do you
guys have anything you want to add
before we wrap up the stream inshallah
the only thing I want to say is
um
subhanallah you know it it's amazing
when someone just accepts Islam because
the prophet peace be upon him he had
mentioned that Islam forgives all sins
so you know no matter what a person has
done in their life
Allah has forgiven them for it any
transgression that they've done against
themselves against God Allah completely
wipes their slate clean and it's it's as
if they're a newborn baby yeah and that
should be something that is um
said more also because I bet a lot of
people who think they've done a lot of
bad they probably get scared about that
but it's like
this is your chance to be reborn like I
know I've done I haven't been the best
of persons my whole life but I know from
this moment right here on
I feel like my sins are forgiven through
this becoming a Muslim and every step
that I take from here on out I mean it
is in the step of light and
righteousness and I promise that I will
not stray away from that this this means
so much to me bro like I I just want to
explode right now because like I can't
wait to like get into it to keep reading
and to just spread the love around it's
just love is beautiful and on top of
that and on top of that every Muslim
that I have come across
it's just the nicest most I went to the
gas station the other day and uh the guy
was there and he said I was like I had
my feeds on I had my beads and he said
oh you Muslim and I was like no but I
was like I'm really thinking about you
know converting and he was like oh he's
like you really she's like you look like
one you look like what I'm like yeah
yeah I was like yeah it's funny he's
like but no he's like you really should
he's like you know what take my number
down this is my name he's like if you
need any help with anything if you're
going through something or anything he's
like just text me we'll talk about it
bro let me tell you that right there
that was my solidifier for this because
I was like I don't even know this man he
just gave me his number tell me to reach
out to talk if I'm depressed or whatever
going through it I'm like this is what
it's about the Brotherhood The
Sisterhood everything about it is just
so unreal that it's too real and it's so
beautiful that and then besides that
it's like you don't join for you know
you don't you don't become a Muslim for
it for that it's a big part of it but
God man God is the one the one that you
need to do this for so um
I agree with that God is the one because
we all do these things for the sake of
Allah now brother at the gas station he
doesn't get money out of this bro if he
helps you if he talks to you everything
we do as Muslims as Believers is for the
sake of Allah we want to earn the
pleasure of Allah and we don't want to
earn the displeasure of Allah and
because you do make an active effort to
strive for being the best performing top
quality brothers and sisters in the
community that we can with Muslims
especially with Muslims
yeah 100 bro like and that's what I that
when I when I saw that I was like he's
not looking for no money he's not
looking I didn't tell him anything about
my life about what I do for work and
nothing he genuinely genuinely looked me
in the eyes like if you need help let me
know bro I talked to a a million people
not one person that said that to me or
have ever said that to me it took the
the one Muslim guy at the gas station to
do that you know like and it's just a
beautiful thing man and like ever since
then
it's funny like now now I see things I
saw a dude praying on his carpet like by
his car now I'm just seeing it
everywhere now that it's like you know
I'm submerged that's a beautiful thing
man every Muslim that I've met has been
so just heartwarming just loving and
want to help a stranger out you don't
know me from nothing and you want to
give me your number you want to help me
out that's beautiful brother you know
and like I'm the same way I'm the same
way I always try to help people out bro
after I see somebody struggling I'll
handle money no matter what I'll even
offer him jobs like you wouldn't want to
get off the street you want to come make
twenty dollars an hour you know like
let's go like I'm I love giving to
people I love helping people so like
when I do the death for me it really
like made me understand like I was like
this is for me this is for me this makes
sense
how can I not want this you know what
I'm saying I'm like look at you guys you
guys you guys got you know decent little
following just the fact that you guys
messaged me back on Instagram like that
quickly
and then you
um how do you pronounce your name
brother
when you message me back that quickly
that that meant a lot to me too to know
you I know you guys are busy you guys
are running your own life but bam it was
like that and it was like look we're
right here where are we did it I
appreciate you guys bro so much bro for
real bro Miller miss you and keep you
steadfast in the dean
um I do want to make a quick one this is
not fear mongering Gotta Give a big
disclaimer but anyone that is out here
accepting that Islam is the truth they
know intuitively this is the reality
this is the truth there's no difference
in opinion there's no doubt about it
don't give in to The Whispers of
shaitaan do not because you will get
these intrusive thoughts like oh I'm not
ready to give up this I'm not ready to
give that up I'm not ready to quit this
or quit that substance I know I got to
pay five times a day now I'm not ready
for that nothing is more important than
in the eyes of Allah you taking that
step by the non-worthy of worship except
Allah
messenger nothing is more important than
that I don't care if you do that and
continue to sin I'm obviously we
shouldn't but it's better that you take
that step and work on yourself take that
step be like you know what let me work
on this before I take that step because
in the latter situation it's not
guaranteed that you're even gonna take
that step right right you're 100 right
and you're speaking to me like directly
with that because I came from heavy
American lifestyle bro like
drinking all the time getting hammered I
smoked a pack of cigarettes a day for a
heavy long time you know I'm I've been
quit now for like two and a half years
um drinking I literally like even even
coming up to this like I haven't been
drinking like partying every single
night you know what I'm saying but like
I I've been slowing it down but bro I've
been waiting for this because like I
know what you said like don't do it
after whatever I've been I've been I've
been doing all I can before this moment
right here let's just say that now that
This Moment's here it's all gonna happen
because I know that I can't let down my
my God and I know now especially now
that I'm here he's watching so anything
that I do and I know of it is almost
like a sin sin you know because it's
like I know that I don't now I'm a
Muslim I know God I know God's here I
know what it is I know what's right and
wrong and if I choose to do that and
knowing that I feel like it's even worse
than just like not knowing that and then
doing the sin you know what I'm saying
so that that's what's going to guide me
to stay righteous bro honestly I promote
sober mind is the best mind you know
what I'm saying you can get high off of
Love and you can get high off of helping
people and just doing this this is my
eye right here talking to you guys you
know is it feeling the love and
spreading the love that's all I'm gonna
do it just being a family man being a
great father teaching my kids how to how
to be awesome and um and become
successful obviously number one too and
the love bro what a wonderful to end it
on and say we wrap it up
um unless you two have anything to say
and I don't know why bro like I have
this this deep inclination that not only
are we gonna do what we can to help you
but I see your energy as a perfect fit
for a man that can give a dawa you know
what I mean and that's to anyone not
just limiting it to anyone that doesn't
have that energy but you have that Vibe
about you that you're passionate about
it and that's something that people of
dawa need and require not to be
overzealous now not to be too much in
people's face but the perfect balance of
like having that that love for the dean
and wanting love for other people what
you want what you want for yourself you
know what I mean you should want for
other people what you want for yourself
we're not out here gate keeping anything
we're not a religion that says you got
to be born into it now come on now we
gotta spread it right exactly exactly
brother yeah um bro um my energy is very
high bro like I've I've opened my mind
so so heavy you know and I'm very I've
educated myself on so many things so
many platforms I've been through so many
things I've been a bad person I've been
through so many experiences to know how
to deal with people and to really be
kind for me to be kind enough to be this
person now it's like a marvelous thing
because I definitely was just like a bad
boy you know but um yeah man I love the
energy I love I love talking to
intellects as well
um just to keep educating myself
oh no
oh
I believe strikes again student mode uh
here we go
did I cut out your audio's a little a
little choppy now
can you hear me good no
it's it's okay it's staticky but we're
kind of nearing the end of the stream
anyway so I think we got the main
messages across
yeah no for sure um yeah if you guys
want to set up chat or whatever you guys
want to talk later let me know
um I appreciate you guys so much bro I
watch you all the time
um that kid Dawn I think that's his name
the the kid who's spying all that young
Don
that was bro that was the craziest thing
that kid that kid needs some help he
needs he needs a lot he needs somebody
to sit down with him and really and
really talk to him because he's just
saying
he's just saying
just just like things that you know
General statements that anybody can say
but it's like
he's lost that boy's lost though and I
can see it he's not genuine about his
own religion like you can see people
that are genuine about their religion
and they got something to say it's like
this kid I feel like he just hopped on
and he's just making like a mockery of
his own religion or whatever whether
he's a Christian and he's making a
mockery of of Muslims and everybody
around just the way he acts but I don't
want to get too deep into that I did
peep that and I needed to bring that up
to you like that kid he needs some he
needs some help bro for sure hopefully
we can we can talk to him one day for
young Don and all the brothers and
sisters too you know Allah says in the
Quran it's not the eyes that are blind
but it's the hearts yeah
for anyone that you guys care about
getting it done inshallah and for this
Mankind in general inshallah
yeah with that being said Buttercup for
everyone who attended and stayed towards
the end but hashtag Jonathan in the chat
if you stayed this long and made it for
the shahada
uh sister for joining us and brother
Jonathan for joining us and taking your
shahada and with that being said
thank you guys so much
laughs